♪
- Les premiers pas, les premiers
sourires, les premiers mots.
Dememements précieux
avec sa fille Ariadne
que savoure Sarah Onyango,
car la vie d'un enfant,
elle le sait, est fre.e.e.
♪ ♪ ♪
Alors, Sarah ne rate aucun
rendez-vous à la clinique,
et veille à ce que sa fille ait
tous les vaccinsninininibles.
Et s'il est une chose qu'elle
craint par-dessus tout, c'est le
paludisme, aussi appelé malaria.
Selon l'OMS, la maladie tue plus
00000000 000 personnes chaque
année; en très grande majorité
des enfants africains de moins
de 5 ans. Une vie fauchée
toutes les deux minutes.
Heureusement, un nouveau vaccin
contre la malaria vient d'être
approuvé par l'Organisation
mondiale de la santé.
(pleurs de bébé)
Dans cetququququque,
il est maintenant prescrit
à tous les nourrissons.
Ce vaccin appelé RTS-S ou
Mosquirix est un développement
majeur dans la lutte
contre la malaria.
L'aboutissement de 30 ans
d'efforts de la part de
chercheurs comme le professeur
Simon Kariuki.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le professeur Kariuki
a consacré sa vie à la lutte
contre le paludisme.
Mais le développement du vaccin.
Premier écueil : la recherche
contre la malaria a longtemps
souffert d'un manque de
financement.
Mais surtout, le parasite qui
cause la maladie, transmis par
des piqûres de moustique, s'est
révélé un adversaire redoutable.
Le vaccin Mosquirix offre
une efficacité d'environ 40 %
contre la malaria.
Mais ce n'est là qu'un début.
D'autres vaccins comme le R21,
actuellement testés, s'annoncent
beaucoup plus efficaces.
Et un traitement basé sur
des anticorps monoclonaux semble
lui aussi très prometteur.
Des pas de géant, franchis
au cours des dernières années
qui permettent enfin
d'être optimiste.
Mais d'ici là, Sarah
va continuer à draîner l'eau
stagnante sur son terrain,
à utiliser les insecticides,
et surtout à dormir sous
une moustiquaire, meilleur moyen
pour protéger celle qu'elle
surnomme sa petite reine.
♪ ♪